a couple of weeks ago we aired a
commercial parody starring our good
friend Nick Offerman in which he was
selling solid wood emojis you know
that's a good-looking fella right there
yeah all right it was supposed to be a
fun little bit ok it was a joke it was a
joke
we've got a couple of chuckles who's
just four goofs and giggles see but
guess what what okay I'll tell you what
our fans said they would really buy them
if we really made them really yes so we
made them and boy oh boy they're selling
like sassafras cupcakes I'm telling you
this is all real here's one right here
besides for licking what else do they do
nothing it's a piece of wood oh cool
yeah first we made a limited edition of
100 woodcut emojis and then what
happened they sold out in like a minute
so the following night we said we'll
sell another 500 and what happened that
they sold out in like a minute
okay completely that's all true in fact
we've sold a thousand wooden emojis and
we're gonna keep selling them see and
all the proceeds this is true all
proceeds are going to the Children's
Defense Fund a very very worth here's
your chance to get on this great deal to
get your very own wood emoji and donate
to a great cause get your fingers a tap
tap tapping on your keyboards and go to
Tilt dot-com slash Team Coco it'll make
you feel like this
that's right and if you don't do it
you'll feel like this
people love these things they're really
buying them it's fantastic this had a
big pile of poo on my head yeah that's
the third time today all right
you